my very first data conference of any
sort and I'm a brand new web developer
and you might say well then what the
heck you're talking to us for because
you guys probably all know more about
Python and more about data science
certainly than I do and the reason I'm
here is because I'm a career changer and
earlier this year I left my job as a
longtime journalist and went to coding
school at boot camp and my instructor
there said that he thought that my
experience dealing with open records and
open data would actually be of interest
to an audience like this and so it was
actually through his nudge who's ever
had a mentor nudge them somewhere and he
nudged me to say you know just put in a
proposal for this this conference and so
that's why I'm here talking amongst
people who I'm meeting all of you for
the very first time and hearing all
kinds of terminology this week that is
both impressive and overwhelming all at
the same time there was one presentation
earlier today actually that is very much
tied to what I'm going to talk about
today and it was the presentation this
afternoon with Colin Copeland and the
cactus group talking about the traffic
stop profiling data for police or any of
y'all at that talk good number of you
all of that was based on a Freedom of
Information request and pollen mentioned
that as he went by and that is what
we're going to talk about in here today
is how do you request information from
the government very how to oriented I'm
just dealing with the basics so that you
understand federal and state and what
the basic steps are but just sort of a
interesting sidelight for me on the
traffic stop profiling data is that last
year early in the year I was the editor
on the story that the Charlotte Observer
did about that data and so later on the
cactus group became involved in turning
it into an entire website and let me
just tell you how helpful that website
would have been when we were trying to
do a story to understand that data the
website would have been hugely helpful
in understanding better what there was
to know from that data so i found that
presentation interesting and
formative from a whole different
perspective and I thought there might be
some overlap and people who were drawn
to that kind of presentation and people
who would come to one like this so we'll
just walk through now how you go about
requesting information from the
government I should ask have any of
y'all ever requested information from
the government a few of you had did you
get what you asked for I got one yes
nobody else Oh two yeses okay in the
news business you get no a lot as well
and so I'll walk through what the basics
are for most of you said that you
understand it and try to tell you some
of what I've learned about how to ask
for data in particular along the way so
I don't have a lot of fancy slides i
just did little web pages here and is
that large enough can you all read it
okay so the first one you might laugh
don't be a jerk and follow the rules you
don't actually have to follow the rules
for a fire request to be legally valid
but it helps so does being nice it helps
so don't pass that over in your quest to
get information you can be a jerk if
called for at the end of the process
when you're still not getting what you
want but always start out nice and don't
be a jerk the next one is might sound
easy be specific not overly broad this
is actually very challenging how do you
frame a request that's broad enough to
capture what you want but not so broad
that it's going to take them forever to
fulfill it and that they find a lot of
roadblocks that mean they can't give it
to you and that sort of thing so you
want to be specific not overly broad and
you want to figure out what data
actually exists if you want to ask for
information from the government a lot of
times it helps if you know what they
have you might not know what the
specific data is but you know what they
collect and you know that they have it
they don't have to do any analyzing or
creating of new records for you you can
only ask for what is the information
that they have and please give that to
us
um and if you can learn with their
collection method is it'll help you
along the way and the example that I
have here is email if you know that in
your request for emails they're going to
do a keyword search to pull out all
relevant emails well then you can
suggest with the keywords are that they
should search for and that will help
them fulfill your request another tip is
number five here is FOIA the foyers and
FOIA the fields and foil the talking
points and FOIA the database layout all
of that can help you figure out what
information the government even has and
all of that is public so you can you can
get access to those things sometimes
easier than you can the data itself and
then you can go further and ask for the
data itself and that's when a lot of
negotiation begins to happen and the
roadblocks happen but when you ask for
things like what foyers have been filed
you might learn that for example the NRA
has the database of concealed carry gun
holder permits right or you might find
that a news organization is asked for a
database that you want you might learn
that the ACLU has asked for a database
that you think oh that sounds pretty
good and you can piggyback on a FOIA
request from somebody else it's public
that they asked for it and you can
piggyback right on top of it find the
right official person and in federal and
state governments that can be a little
bit different but find the official
right person but also find the
unofficial person who really knows those
are not always in fact often not the
same person there's an official who's in
charge how's this in real life right
you're in your workplace there's
somebody who's in charge and then
there's somebody who actually knows the
work it's the same way when you're
trying to acquire the data find out
who's in charge of releasing things but
then find out who really knows about the
information as well when you're talking
to them it's good to go ahead and make a
verbal request your first request for
information does not have to be in
writing and a lot of times it can help
you learn better how to frame your
request they might mention issues
they're concerned about and if there are
things that you can work around well
then that gives you information right
then that you can work around if if it's
some kind of concern that you can't
compromise on well at least you know
that's where the arguments going to be
and you can go ahead and start making
your arguments for why that information
should be released another tactic is
that if you believe a certain record
reap exists you've done your research
and you've talked to people and you
found things on the Google and you're
pretty sure that there's a certain
record that exists describe it when
you're making your request in as much
detail as you can because if they
realize that you know something exists
they're actually sometimes less likely
to give you a hard time about it and
they may even if you take any kind of
ill motive away from it they may not
realize something like that exists until
you describe it in that detail and then
it brings clarity to their search for
information always cite the statute
whether you're dealing with federal or
state always cite the statute that gives
you standing immediately to be asking
for what you're asking for and always
keep a log of your communication that
comes in really handy if they don't just
immediately turn over information if you
have a log of what you asked for and
when you asked for it that's really
handy I actually have a what a real
simple log looks like that I can show
you right quick this is from well I
thought I knew how to zoom is that large
enough go a little little bigger this is
a log from a request to get medical
examiner data from the state of North
Carolina and it's from the Charlotte
Observer our data reported there Gavin
off just kept a simple log of when he
asked for different information now this
was one request and look at the date
that it starts februari 2012 and it
continues through 2013
we asked for an update they provided the
dictionaries we asked for all publicly
available records it goes into 2013 when
the state provided the rest of the data
they provided the first batch of data in
2013 so it was a long road to finally
get what was public information all
along it wasn't like there were legal
questions about what was public and what
wasn't but by keeping a log and
referencing that log in your follow up
communication you can start to put
weight on an agency to respond I just
showed you one that shows a really long
time line that was to help you get your
heads around the idea that you you
probably need to be patient and be
reasonable about the time periods that
it takes for government to respond
especially to really large data requests
and it also helps if you can copy
someone on your request sometimes it's
the worker bee you talked to who
actually knows the stuff sometimes it's
a sympathetic department head it
actually can be an elected official if
there's an elected official who has a
vested interest in the information that
you're trying to acquire copy them on
your communications with the agency that
you're requesting the data from it can
be a local municipal official it can be
a member of Congress it could be a u.s.
senator if you've if you think you've
got them in your corner you don't have
to have their permission to copy
somebody just if you think that they
might actually care about what you're
doing and you want to you want them to
know if you get rejected on an open
records request think about who that
might be and include them in your
communications couple things worth
noting is that a first there's a federal
and state laws that govern this right
federal and state and all the states are
different about what's open and what's
the process to do it and submission
preferences very some of them want it
walked in some of them want email some
of them want snail mail some of them
have a
form you have to submit whatever their
rule is on that just try to abide by it
and they'll tell you what it is if you
do it the wrong way they'll tell you
what the right way is and sometimes
there is a fee so you have to be
prepared for a reasonable fee those fees
are supposed to be reasonable they're
supposed to cover actual copying costs
including digital copying costs and
another thing just to be aware of is
that in this era of data there's a lot
of commingling of public information
with non-public information in those
databases the government cannot withhold
a database in its entirety simply
because there's non-public information
contained in it the government at its
own cost has to redact that and give you
the remainder of what's there and you're
supposed to know what's redacted like
you're supposed to know that that's a
column heading for the name of the
police officer and that it's been
redacted so those are just some things
worth noting and I mentioned that
there's federal and state federal has I
won't go into great detail on these but
federal has some very specific
exemptions and this is just a quick
overview so that you know what they are
anything's top-secret give it up you're
not going to get it unless somebody
leaks it to you but you can't request it
and things that are strictly about the
internal workings of agencies Congress
president the federal courts none of
those are covered by FOIA trade secrets
some kinds of financial information
that's confidential and this one on
internal memos that are deliberative
this is a federal exemption that does
not apply to most states but internal
federal agency communications where
they're just trying to decide what to do
those are not considered public at the
state level they are but at the federal
level they're not and things that would
be an unwarranted invasion of privacy
for individuals that oftentimes is very
protected as well as law enforcement
records that would compromise a fair
trial or compromise an investigation or
this is an interesting one or what
disclosed techniques and would disclose
investigative techniques I think it was
last year the Charlotte Observer was
seeking information on stingrays anybody
know what a stingray is a stingray is a
it's a doodad you'll probably know the
innards of it and how to describe it but
it's a doodad that can intercept cell
communications and the police in
Charlotte were going to the courts and
getting permission to use this to track
criminals right they were getting the
level of approval from a judge that you
would get for something called a pen
register from the old-timey phone
company and the Stingray is actually a
far more powerful device than the pen
register and yet that's the level of
approval they were getting from the
court and so long they've got very weird
about the Stingray and what information
they wanted to release on it but the
short of it is that they changed the
standard by which they had to get a
judge's permission the judges didn't
even realize what they were signing off
on and they changed their standard for
saying yes to use of a stingray they
just required more proof from police
officers of what they needed it for and
how they intended to use it rather than
what was really a very perfunctory sign
off that had existed before they also
federally are not allowed to you can't
request under the open records thinks
they're about supervising the banks and
other financial institutions and this
one I always find kind of fascinating
geological and geophysical information
on gas and oil wells has his own
exemption in the federal code one thing
that's good about dealing with FOIA at
the federal level is that they're very
clear about having FOIA officers in FOIA
contacts and foil liaisons the state
level can vary wildly on who is
designated and who thinks they're
responsible but the federal level people
have FOIA contact attached to their name
their list I have links later in this
where you can see the list of all
agencies and who the FOIA contacts are
for those federal agencies the law says
that they have to
20 business days to respond to a request
but not in real life so you should just
be prepared that they might acknowledge
receipt of your request but they may not
actually provide the data in that 20
days in fact consider yourself lucky if
you get the data in 20 days there isn't
always a backlog and there's an
executive order that's been in place for
a few years now requiring agencies to
reduce their backlog by ten percent each
year so there again they claim they're
getting a little bit better about the
time that it takes to get these and they
track it and report it on websites and
all things very official in North
Carolina I'll focus on North Carolina I
do later have links to their
organizations that compile
state-by-state open records information
that will help you deal with other
states but I'll focus on North Carolina
here how many of y'all live and work in
North Carolina okay okay good reason to
focus on North Carolina so I mentioned
that the state is not as formal as the
federal government in designating FOIA
contacts the public official who's in
charge of an office is considered the
custodian of the record and so that's
how you make your request to is the
custodian of the record and they don't
have that same exemption that the
federal government does for deliberative
process memos in North Carolina you
might think that you could go to the
Attorney General to get support on
someone releasing open records but
indeed the Attorney General's power on
this is limited they can issue opinions
and they can advise and they can mediate
but they do not actually have
enforcement power if you want to enforce
someone's failure to comply with an open
records request you have to go to court
so that's why the media ends up being
one of the upholders of the public
access right on this is because the
media has lawyers that will go to court
and say we need this information and the
agencies know that and so they sometimes
are more likely to comply I'd say this
is the the joke for this session but
it's real
right now there's a lawsuit pending by
from the news organizations against the
north carolina state government for
being so slow to reply to Freedom of
Information requests and it's moving
through the courts the governor tried to
have the case dismissed and the judge
said a lot of harsh things actually
about the current government and said
that that case could move forward so
maybe we'll see some change in North
Carolina on how quickly they respond
there's no time limit federal asks that
they respond within 20 days and they
have some pressure to reduce a backlog
but in North Carolina there's no time
limit at all on when they need to
respond a lot of other states do have a
time limit but not North Carolina one
handy thing to know is that every public
agency by law in North Carolina has to
have an index of their databases and
that index is a public record and this
heading here on databases this is what's
required to be in that index they have
to include their the list of the data
fields the record layout frequency of
updates description of forms that are
used and they also have to include in
their the schedule of fees for how to
copy it and they also have to include in
there what forms can they provide that
database in so asking for the index of
databases from an agency is a really
good starting point if you think that
there's a database that you want to tap
into and again you can't ask them to
create a database that doesn't exist
right you can only ask for records that
exist so this index of databases is very
very handy very important and money can
sometimes be a barrier to the general
public so if your employer is behind
this public records request maybe your
employer is willing to pay whatever they
ask but a lot of times the cost that
they come up with it's become a new
tactic to block access to some records
is to have very high costs that aren't
justified and so you should be prepared
to pay some costs
if of copying a database and making it
available to you but request an estimate
in writing before you agree to it so
that you know what you're in for even if
you're willing to pay it ask them to
give you the estimate any way you want
them to know that you understand your
rights and that you want these things
handled according to the law the actual
cost of the copies is what they're
supposed to be able to charge for they
can charge extra for staff time if they
need to do a lot of work to prepare a
database to copy it they can charge for
that and if you if you are somehow lucky
enough to work out with somebody that
they will they're willing to create or
compile a record that doesn't exist but
they want to charge you for it you could
you could work that out so the law does
allow them to charge you for doing work
that they weren't doing for their own
purposes but they're willing to do it as
long as you're willing to pay for it
it's not exactly a contract arrangement
or anything like that but it can can
work for you sometimes you can appeal
the cost of the estimate and just a
reminder that they can't charge you to
have to separate out a non-public from
public data in a database this is just a
quick rundown here of personnel files
being generally exempt confidential
communications with lawyers and their
clients trade secrets you can't look at
individual income tax returns they don't
allow you to do that one thing that is
kind of interesting in our state is that
the SBI is completely exempt from the
releasing their law enforcement records
CMPD charlotte-mecklenburg Police
Department all the police departments
and sheriff departments in the state
they do have to release certain basic
information on all traffic stops and
other investigations but the SBI is
exempt you also can't FOIA the database
of 900 x for a community that's just
meant to be a privacy protection same
thing with autopsy photos and audio
video and
thing along that line sensitive public
security information and the last one
industrial or business expansion while
in negotiation that's about incentives
which are a politically sensitive thing
in our state when is the right time to
spend public money to lure a business to
your area when is it a good economic
development move and when is it a
handout for business and they are not
required to share that information while
things are being negotiated after a deal
is settled they're supposed to share all
of that information it took the observer
a year to get information on the efforts
to land Electrolux as a client in North
Carolina something that that North
Carolina I think did not succeed at and
it still took a year to land that
information in the office so it can take
a good while to get the information to
come along just to demystify this a
little bit you don't have to know the
ins and outs to make a request i'm going
to show you hear a letter that you can
send without knowing is this subject to
an exemption is there going to be a fee
for this does this record absolutely
exists the way i think it does you can
ask for information without knowing all
of those answers the law actually says
that that it's their intent is to make
information available to the public so
the process itself should not be that
owner is to get started the hard part is
always in following up and trying to get
them to actually release the information
so this is a letter I'm just scrolling
through it here I'll zoom out so you can
see oops that's a little too zoomed and
you can see that it's really just a
letter and I'll zoom in a little bit
more so you can see more what it says
it's very old-fashioned like if you took
a typing class when you're at camp
somewhere I don't know when you would
have taken a typing class this is an
old-fashioned letter format and whether
you're sending an email or whether
you're sending a registered letter not a
bad tactic a registered letter
put the date on it and put the contact
information of who you're sending it to
do it in the old timey style so that
you've got a very clean clear record of
what you were asking for who you sent it
to and the date that you made the
request even though that information is
available in in the digital world it's
readily available put it in the text of
your letter if you end up in arguments
over data that's simpler to read your
documents are the better and a plain old
letter with a letterhead like this goes
a long way so you're just open with I'm
requesting the information under either
the federal act or the state act and
that's what a simple reference to it
looks like it's not real complicated and
you say i'm requesting the following
data in whatever digital form these
records may be kept you also could ask
for it in a specific format if you know
that's available and then you just list
the example I gave here is that the
medical examiner database so in this
request we ask for the data structure
and the dictionaries we ask for all
publicly available tables and fields we
ask for all public records from 2006 to
present so it's not real detailed it's
all within the medical examiner
information system all public records in
the medical examiner information system
so it's not like all for the state of
North Carolina but within that database
and they actually when they fulfilled
that request with held several years of
data and it took a second request to get
those years filled in and here asking
them to label the tables you can ask for
something basic so that you understand
what they've just delivered without
having to study it to just figure out
what label belongs on it and in this
case we asked for them to be put on a
delimited text files put posted on the
ftp site as delimited text files
you can also say that you're willing to
provide an external storage device
whatever it takes to take delivery be
flexible about that if you can and
sometimes they deliver by email
sometimes by EFT FTP sites sometimes
it's on a jump drive I've got a lot of
CDs that have public data on them and
you just run by and pick them up and i
think that the traffic stop data I think
Colin said that it was on CDs and so it
comes in all forms and oftentimes it's
if your setup is like mine a lot of
times you have format problems and you
end up having to get a viewer to open
things and that kind of stuff but the
next part of your letter simply
addresses that you understand there may
be reasonable fees I've put in here a
potential request for a waiver if you
are going to use this as public
information for the public you can
request a waiver of the fee that's
probably the one area that the media
gets a break is that a lot of times fees
are reduced for the media but the media
doesn't have access to information that
you guys don't also have access to it's
just about how much you can have to pay
for it and sometimes the media gets a
break sometimes if you can make a legal
argument that yours is for the public
good not commercial gain then you can
get get the fees waived this next graph
is very important if you take the
position that these records are not
subject to the open records law put that
in writing for me please and that's a
very powerful thing when they get ready
to don't don't accept it verbally the
law actually says that if asked they
must put that in writing so ask them to
put in writing why they have
specifically what statute their sighting
or what legal case they're citing to
withhold that information and is very
powerful to ask them to do that and then
this this paragraph under the federal
FOIA I look forward to hearing from you
within 20 business days but II
when you're making a request to someone
not subject to a timeline consider what
might be a reasonable time and ask for
that say I'd like to hear from you I
look forward to hearing from you and put
a date in there it don't just leave it
open-ended because again the key here is
going to be your follow-up and your
record-keeping to show how you've been
asking for it and how they failed to
meet deadlines and you've asked for it
and they failed to meet deadlines and
without responding and those kinds of
things are very powerful should you end
up in front of the judge and always
include your contact information and
offer to answer any questions that
sounds basic and notice at the bottom I
got my CCS to my elected official in my
department head and even my lawyer if
I've got one the head of an institution
who might might care about things I have
some additional resources here but just
to just to recap decide you want
something I think that's probably why
you're all here is your kind of
wondering maybe you want something from
the government what kind of data they
have decide on something you want and go
ask for it this really is an essential
part of democracy to have open
decision-making to have transparency
transparency builds trust i think i
heard that come from colin earlier today
transparency does build trust people
right now have problems trusting their
government they have problems trusting
each other and problems trusting the
media but transparency can help with
that so please decide on something you
want and try to figure out what exists
and then go ask for it you should check
around see if anybody's got something
that you could piggyback on ask nicely
ask clearly put it in writing copy
someone who cares and might stand with
you in that request and then of course
wait and check back and wait and check
back and keep a log and make sure that
you've got that to fall back on you can
appeal and even though the Attorney
General can't enforce it for you the
Attorney General can at least weigh in
on what he thinks might be public about
that and additionally here I just have a
list of more help and I'll make sure
that this is posted
actually on my website that mentioned
that I'm a web developer for hire I'm
just out of boot camp and I need a job
but on my website here I'll make sure
that i have this website linked from
there so that you can see the resources
that have been compiled anybody have
questions can you request previous foia
requests for both state and federal yes
so we can make a request to the state
for previous foia requests yes um if you
do that does it give you the name of you
requested it yes um and then have you
had success contacting those people for
the same data like maybe it's easier to
get from them and then to wait on the
government again indeed that has
happened before and it it depends on who
it is sometimes people who want the same
data have very different purposes for it
and I can assure you for example that
the NRA is not willing to share
databases with mainstream media and does
it also give any indication of the cost
they had to pay because I'm just
wondering if there's any way to track
like what's reasonable or how they
charge you you know one of the resources
that i have listed here is a mock rock
com anybody know muck rock mock rock is
actually I I don't know muck rock except
that they exist um it's a service and
they they have some information
state-by-state on what average response
times might be and also what average
fees might be so looking at mock rock
can give you an idea of what to expect
mock rock also you could pay them to
represent you in a open records request
at either the federal or state level you
can pay them to do it for you and they I
think that when they a request is
fulfilled through their request they
posted online for everyone to see so you
could
you could download from there so I had a
couple questions actually first one was
related to sort of we heard a session a
couple days back on quartz and sort of
citations and court rulings and things
like that does that fall under FOIA or
is that some other sort of mechanism
totally it it's at the federal level
FOIA does not apply to the federal court
system so that's completely handled
completely separately and then at the
state level it's addressed in the open
records law but a great deal of
information is you know the courts have
discretion to seal documents all the
time grand jury proceedings are
specifically outlined in law is being
protected but the things that are part
of an open court file you can absolutely
go get North Carolina is not at the
front of the curve on digitizing the
court process though and so if you
especially if you want databases the
state of North Carolina has some work to
do still for you to even have a database
to request second second question was
related to like when you had your CC
list do you have any recommendations on
like engaging with the media to perhaps
champion your interest in terms of you
know influencing or pushing the pushing
the request forward I can tell you that
when I worked at the Charlotte Observer
people cc'd us on all kinds of things
they sent to the government and then
they send me a copy of it to when you
see see somebody just in case you don't
remember from your typing class that
means you really do make a copy and send
it to them okay so like that's what's
powerful because maybe they do see it
and get interested so I would see see
the North Carolina Press Association and
also the reporters Committee for the
freedom of the press they care about
these things a lot and over at elon they
actually host the open government center
there and so copying people at the
in government center thus it's called a
sunshine law the sunshine on public
decision making and Ilan is very active
in supporting people normal people who
make requests and my final question the
promise I've been following the San
Bernardino story out west related to the
iphone sort of cracking case and sort of
these Freedom of Information requests
have been coming around that recently I
think in the last day or two they made a
request now seeking the name of the
contractor they don't want to know the
method of how it was done but they want
to know the name of the contractor that
actually they hired so I wanted to hear
your thoughts about where do you think
that'll land and whether it fits under
that definition of a forget you said a
method yeah it's the name of a
contractor is going to be really hard to
withhold that's that's just me talking
that's not a legal ruling at all but I
think they'll have a hard time with
holding the name of a contractor
contracts are fabulous databases by the
way if you requested the database of
contracts from any municipality in this
state you would find interesting things
and if you requested the databases from
all of them you'd find even more
interesting things if you correlated
them any other questions I have a
question um how did you have to do have
you done any Freedom of Information
requests on like social media aren't
things that public officials post part
of the public record I you know private
industry is not subject to open records
request at all twitter has an API you
can go into their API and pull out
whatever the heck you want to in fact I
actually I've mentioned I'm a bootcamp
graduate of my final project I tapped
into the Twitter API and pulled out
tweets of presidential candidates and
you can get a whole lot more through the
Twitter API than you can by going on
Twitter and just searching you go into
the API you can get whatever you want
and
do all kinds of math on it um you know I
actually should mention private
companies are not subject to the freedom
of information laws unless they are in
some kind of funny place where they
actually are a kind of a government
entity hospitals in North Carolina are
an example of that in both wake and
Mecklenburg counties these private
hospitals are actually the public
hospital and there have been a lot of
arguments about what they have to
disclose and in the end they have to
disclose a fair amount of public
information so because two quick
questions one you talked about standing
like is in North Carolina resident what
I have standing to request like Arkansas
public records from the state of
Arkansas or today can they make it argue
about standing for you that's an
excellent question and it varies by
state in North Carolina I don't think
you have to be a resident but I think in
Virginia you do have to be a resident
and you know the law is just in this
area are really different South Carolina
has a time limit believe it or not South
Carolina is stricter about providing
public information than North Carolina
is that sounded kind of disparaging of
South Carolina but but they they
actually have a time limit on when you
need to reply and I think North Carolina
and Tennessee often ranked at the bottom
in the country when people do
assessments of this North Carolina and
Tennessee are 40-somethings like 45 ish
in the country on that Virginia and
South Carolina do better they're more
like you know in the top 20 so it's it's
really interesting how things vary from
state to state and then my other
question was does this basic principle
apply to you like the Department of
Public Instruction and getting
information about this information they
record in the there's a lot of privacy
things around education data but at a
high level understanding what their
tracking yes a great deal of information
is available from the school districts
and one of the links that i have here is
to the Raleigh News & Observer which is
a sister publication of the Charlotte
Observer and notice salaries of
government workers are public
information including
employees of the universities and I'm
talking your name and how much you make
and what your title is that's all public
information and these databases of
government workers and their salaries
are hugely popular with the public
people use them all the time but in here
they also have databases from NC school
performance and grades and this database
on the lottery money I don't think it'll
be this weekend but I still have some
friends in the Charlotte newsroom and I
hear there's a story coming on the North
Carolina lottery and some interesting
things that are up with the people who
sell the lottery tickets maybe something
about frequency of winning maybe yeah no
I mean the retailers themselves might
possibly so before we get into trouble
let's thank our speaker